he is so funny about wanting a fitness
center but he doesn't work out maybe he
wants the front of selfies I probably
tell you way too much information I'm an
only child though okay I know too much
information she's like the ultimate best
friend like I could go to her for like
anything we're pretty similar in the
fact that we communicate by constant
disagreement we disagree about stuff I
am so uncomfortable because I definitely
like get on his nerves baby sounds of
man I'm ready to move away from the
parental so I can see my mom I can see
what she's looking at and I can hear her
but she can not hear me which is great
cuz we're gonna have some comments
alright let's look for some apartments
and apartments got to have air
conditioning a nice balcony I would want
a studio apartment but it has to be
affordable
definitely a spa a sauna I want to be
closer to like the Hollywood Los Angeles
area no room for my dog definitely gotta
be pet friendly a gym and a pool start
here Los Angeles yes definitely you know
roommates let's just put him far enough
away from me more creates a good
distance comfort level for both of us
okay and I'm gonna find a be an
apartment it's been living in an
eight-by-ten room for last couple years
so he doesn't need much more space than
that I don't I don't think we discuss
that Wow these pictures are great oh
this one it's like really nice but like
I just feel like I don't want to be in
downtown okay Lydia
Oh music and we are going to save this
one Judy she doesn't listen she's not
taking into consideration that I
probably don't want to have a roommate
this is really close to my job literally
that's like down the street from her job
I cannot look there air conditioning
definitely doesn't need it dishwasher
for sure he is the dishwasher oh my
goodness and none of them are in North
Hollywood or Sherman Oaks our Burbank
she should be looking at studio
apartments something we could have a
further look at it's not too terrible
willing to go ahead and part this I'm
gonna put a heart next to this one he's
gonna love them I like one of them I
think we're ready to go talk about this
let's talk about your decision-making
he was a goalie yeah okay I definitely
do you didn't give any options for like
Burbank or no we can always end up there
but this is pretty you exactly out on a
bad definitely is there two to three
bedrooms though unless you're planning
on me moving in with you I can get it
you know the different roommate I feel
like this apartment will be perfect I
like this is everything I've been
looking for so check availability the
mix really is exciting I was really
excited to move to my first apartment we
have to go everything together so nice
yeah I actually like this one the
bathtub is nice so let's okay - let's
check availability you did manage to
find a few good spots though on your own
so I gotta give you credit for that I
think we did really good without the
trouble game we did trouble we did
really good we narrowed it down you'll
be moving out really soon I'm gonna miss
you thank you and that got it
No
[Music]